you
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm super excited for today's
episode we're featuring Neel Nanda we're
gonna be talking about culture of comedy
we have so much to chat about I'm super
excited oh man thank you grab me man I'm
excited to be here I love how we ended
up finding each other and you were in
the Bay visiting from LA and we had the
psychedelic seminars going on and we
were looking for a cool act and I was
like you're really good come do the act
and you opened it up crushed it
thank you man so super fun super fun
yeah no no more about psychedelics than
I thought I did
yeah your stories were good your first
accidental experience there's yeah yeah
I I thought it was a weed brownie well
ended up being a mushroom brownie being
a dog [ __ ] mushroom brownie I can't
believe it tasted so bad your your yeah
your backgrounds great you you did
stand-up on Jimmy Kimmel you also have
worked on with Comedy Central you've
done some was advice right there have
been like and Hulu and just on Amazon
Prime recently and so yeah just a couple
things here and there yeah and then you
produce a weekly show called unnecessary
evil yes a weekly show in Los Angeles in
Santa Monica at the Westside comedy
theater every Friday at 8 p.m. I've been
doing that for six years there'll be six
years next week November 2nd or 6-year
anniversary can't believe some in six
years see that's a big deal cuz you know
you've been doing stand-up for almost 10
years now since 2009 and once you gained
six years of producing a show where you
actually you know pay comics people pay
for tickets and you pay comics that
learning how to do that
week after week for six years is a huge
deal for experience and
learning the ecosystem how things work
yes the ecosystem that's what I call it
always yeah the ecosystem of comedy
comedy ecosystem now at the bottom of
the ecosystem yeah it's been a really
great experience I've been able to work
with some incredible comedians some of
my heroes this year alone Adam Sandler
dropped in whoa that was crazy
whoa that was it you wanna hear the
story I do want to hear the story and I
want to unpack also your life and
upbringing and the path of comedy but
let's unpack that of Sandwich story yeah
yeah I just dropped it yeah so I don't
want to elite I don't wanna leave a
cliffhanger so Adam Sandler was he's had
dropped into the theater once or twice
and I believe he was working on his
Netflix special that's coming out in two
days I think and so he was actually he I
believe he lives on the west side
somewhere I don't know I don't I didn't
stalk him that hard and I had seen him
walking the streets of Santa Monica half
an hour before my show and so I I saw
him in the distance and I ran up to him
and I stopped like feet before like 10
feet before I reached him and I caught
my breath I didn't wanna look like I ran
up to him yeah
so I can't my breath a nice sped walked
past him I gave him a double tick and of
course he gave me the hey how you doing
hey hi and he started broke on to his
song about his mom and he he gave me the
you know he gave me the hey hey dawn and
I was like hey I'm sorry to bother you
but and he his he was with his wife he
introduced me to his wife because like I
was my wife I believe her name was
Jackie Jackie Sandler and he was like
hey is my wife Jackie hey how you doing
my wife Jackie
that's my terrible and I'm sailing
oppression and I met both of them and I
asked him nicely like hey man I got a
show it's starting in half an hour if
you want to drop by you can do as much
time as you want and he was like I don't
have anything to work I'm not that funny
I was like dude you're out of Stanley
you can literally
into the microphone if that's possible
you could do it and everyone would lose
their mind and he was like nah you young
guys are so funny and I can't get no you
know I was like come on dude we'd love
to have you
we're there every Friday at 8 o'clock
and he goes every Friday I go yeah it's
every Friday he goes 8 o'clock I was
like yeah you can come by whenever you
want and he was like ok I'll come by
left I didn't see him again for it's
until months later I'm at my show I'm on
stage I'm on stage I'm performing and
I'm having I'm having one of those fun
sets with some crowd work and I'm
messing around trying some new material
I remember thinking like I was a really
fun set I'm having a good time and I get
offstage and the comic who was supposed
to be up next was supposed to close it
out and he's not in the wing of the
stage usually they're in the wing leg to
get up and I was like where is he you
know and the host goes up on stage and
he's backstage I got dude you're next
what do you my show so I'm like I know
the running or what I'm I hey we're
running late I need you to get up on
stage and get you know get this show
wrapped up he goes no I'm after Sandler
I said what and he goes yeah Sandler
dropped in I said you're kidding I
thought he was joking I was a caja dude
you need to get on stage right now and
then I hear the host out there and she's
like she's like okay guys please put
away all your cell phones no photography
no video no that and I'm just like what
is she prepping for and Adam Sandler was
behind the bar and he sneaks out from
behind the bar key don't want to come
backstage so you have to walk through
the audience to get backstage usually
the comments get there before the show
starts they're like right around the
show starts so they're already back
there but he didn't want to walk through
they coordinated with someone else to
surprise you yeah I guess well he
coordinated the bar like he just he
walked in and of course the club isn't
gonna be like no I'll get out of here
you know hey who are you
you know he told me that I could do a
set whenever I want basically yeah so he
must have said that the bartender or
something the bartender's like all right
wait here
you up next and then the bartender must
have related relayed the message to the
green room so he goes on stage and he
said I was like how much time is he
doing and the host was like he said he's
gonna do five thirty thirty five minutes
and to the net I wasn't out of sailor
fly which nobody's stopping him of
course nobody's like nobody cares the
theater is really cool about if somebody
huge drops in like we've had other
people like Hannibal and Howie Mandel
and Ali Wong and Damon Wayans and people
and whenever people like that drop in
the theaters very cool about just let
him run it's good for the theater it's
good for the show if you are next show
starts like we just say oh it's cuz Adam
Sandler dropped in and now that I was
just here you know and so he he does
like thirty minutes and I run up to him
on his way out to thank him just to say
hey thanks for dropping miles really
nice of you and he gives me the oh man
made my life but he gave me the oh yes
was your show I was like yeah man thanks
for coming by it's like yeah it was nice
meeting you girls and you were really
funny and I was like he saw myself he
told me I was funny I lost my mind and
then I told her I said anytime you want
to drop in we're here every Friday goes
every Friday yeah eight o'clock I was
like yeah and he's like okay and he
dropped in one other time when I was out
of town but yeah it was that was Christ
that's my own story I love that story
there's there's two things that I find
fascinating about that story
the first thing there's a lot of things
but these are the two I really stick out
I want to share first thing is that I
love your initiative because most people
don't know that they have power and all
they have to do is go and take the risk
of seeing the person that they want to
talk to and like you did it very
strategically ran up there and you
waited to you know calm down catch your
breath and then approach them all like
hey oh yeah and then it's like you know
you're not asking for anything you're
just saying I produce a show I'm gonna
plant a seed and just maybe it'll get
watered you don't have any expectations
yeah and boom it happened and then the
other
cool thing that I thought was that was
great so that means take the risk take
those moments always always take always
take the risk the worst thing that can
happen is you can say no get out of my
face okay and then I have that story and
I can have you telling you that story
just planted the seed and it just didn't
get water and then just ranting seeds
and eventually they get water yeah and
so then the other thing that I thought
was really awesome was just how funny it
is that like a high-level comedic node
can just pop into any way anywhere
anywhere I've seen I've seen people pop
huge people pop into like a 12 person
show or like I've seen you know it's so
cool it's it's insane especially in Los
Angeles but yeah
anybody can pop it anywhere if somebody
lives in the area and they're just
happened to be around they might pop in
we had another instance where we had
Kevin Nealon who he and he was just
hanging out at the bar at our show I was
like what do you and I didn't notice him
my girlfriend was at the show she goes
Kevin Nealon at the bar I said no he's
not as probably some dude who looks like
Kevin Nealon and then I walked over the
bar and you can't mistake Kevin Nealon
and I was that's Kevin Nealon he's just
chilling at the bar and I was like hey
man would you
I produce a show would you like to do 10
15 minutes we'd love to have you and he
was super nice these are the nicest
thing that anyone's ever said because
most comedians with you just say yes or
no and he said as long as I don't bump
anybody as long as I don't take
anybody's time as long as I don't take
anybody's time I'm happy to go up and I
was like and we have having to have a
drop out that day so I think we have
time I was like we have a drop out and
somebody someone didn't show up and now
Kevin Nealon here and he went up and he
did great it was awesome I love Kevin
Neil he's so funny but that's cool
there's also something about being able
to go and practice your set that's kind
of why a lot of high level notes just
you know they can be on their own time
whenever they want to go and practice
some material you see how it resonates
with people but it's also crazy that the
higher level you are you could like you
said just [ __ ] into the mic and yeah and
they lose their mind well I think a lot
of these bigger comics want to work out
their material in smaller rooms and they
want to cultivate their new material
before
they have fans pay money to see them and
they want to have their material
polished so that when their fancy them
and that pay you know the big bucks to
pick you know that that's like a you
know think I've got a babysitter and
then I gotta go to a theater and they
pay for parking and two drinks and blah
blah and you know that's a night for
them it's like two hundred three hundred
dollars you know per couple and
sometimes even more and they don't want
to put on a shitty show so they drop
into all the clubs and all the spots
that's how you Joe the feelers out for
your comedy for what I wrote that's so
interesting
okay Mia walk us through what happened
to get you here where are when did you
move to do reborn in the u.s. yes okay
when did your parents move to the US oh
wow
I'm we're from India so my dad was
actually already in Atlanta Georgia he's
at Georgia Tech engineering school and
he the way arranged marriage worked back
then from what my understanding was he
put like an ad in the indie newspaper he
was like hey who wants to [ __ ] and he
like put you know baby corn me what's up
you know Georgia Turkey yeah Georgia
Tech Atlanta was just that's all it was
he didn't have to be like I got a huge
dick he was like Atlanta and there were
like America and so like women were
flocking to him and he so he put an ad
in the Indian newspaper and my mom my
grandpa saw this was like Georgia Tech
you know engineering you know it was
like he's studying Computer Engineering
and in India India India or United
States exactly yeah eeny meeny miny the
one in America take that one so she she
wrote my dad a handwritten letter and
this is I always I joke about us on
stage but she wrote a handwritten letter
to a bunch of guys in India and my dad
was the first one to get back to her
which means he got back to a from
America I always joke about that's how
horny he was he beat the dudes who could
have walked to my mom's mailbox seeing a
huntsman like okay here you go
but my dad was like oh my god hey girl
in India wants to marry me and he says
you know like what's up baby I am ready
to fly to India right
and so he was you know they met he flew
to India to meet her you met their
family I'm a cramp a major my dad had a
green card
interesting this happens about an equal
areas of the like caste system where the
socio a contingent be I mean it was such
a different time than the caste system
has kind of dissipated but I kind of
equate the caste system almost to like
civil rights and everything like when
civil rights ended it wasn't just like
cool for blue you know like it wasn't
just awesome for black people it wasn't
just like you know when slavery ended it
wasn't just like Oh everything's good
now you know and still feeling it yeah
it's still it's systematically you know
in place so the caste system is the same
way where it's like if you weren't
untouchable or if you or whatever you're
still homeless you're still like we may
not call you an untouchable we may not
call you a Kshatriya or a Brahmin or
whatever but you're still rich and
you're still you know live on the
streets
so yeah his socioeconomic class still in
this class system still exists in India
it's not as prevalent but like I said
there's just residual effects so my
parents were both in an upper-middle
class of the system and yeah they he was
approved by my parents family and my
dad's family was in India as well they
met they got married I believe within
the next like two weeks yes it was quick
quick it was mad quick and I know how
you vibe with the person figure it out
yeah they didn't she vied with his
profile she was really into his profile
pic and and he showed up and he looked
like his profile pic so she's good
enough Hey Dude silts the other yeah
they're still together out you know it's
funny brothers and sisters I have a
sister and your sister older yeah and
it's funny because I get that a lot
where people are like oh your parents
were arranged and they're still together
yeah because divorce in India is a
[ __ ] sin it's like blasphemy if you
divorce somebody it's like it's worse
than like a
Daltry or like murder it's like murder
basically it's just not a cultural thing
it's becoming more common in India which
i think is great because a lot of
relationships there are a lot of abusive
relationships and a lot of shitty
relationships in the indian within the
indian culture and they don't divorce
because it's so frowned upon culturally
it's becoming more common now in 2018
but it's worth leaving so you can find
some of that aligns with your soul more
Riya
or Allah or someone who does not
necessarily the sixty percent divorce
rate that the unit yeah we don't need
this sixty now I think more than half
it's more than half that's not good yeah
we don't need fifty we did twenty thirty
is fun you know let's go twenty-five
let's start there you know start with a
quarter to make sure that we know that
the person is the right one for us
prior to especially having a child with
them right the disaster okay so right so
you know it's funny because like people
are like wow they're still together
still laugh each other it's like I don't
know if they love each other I don't
know about that that that's it's like a
business relationship at this point it's
like you know what I mean so it's it's
not I don't know I don't know if my
parents I've never even seen my parents
showed each other affection so I have no
idea it's what you had to when you were
like three or five or seven or something
no when you were younger I don't know if
they I don't know if they've ever hugged
in front of me I don't know it's just
not a cultural I mean well it's I don't
even know if it's not a cultural thing
because I know Indian people that
there's no effect that's correct yeah
they don't yeah Indian people don't kiss
that's a cultural thing you know it's
all business no my parents didn't they
don't really show affection towards each
other and it's very interesting it's
very much like a business but it's like
a partnership more than it is a
relationship or what I perceive as a
relationship or what Western culture
would perceive as a related dad and mom
give you that love and hug and affection
absolutely not
I'm sorry I maybe laugh and so much man
not at all man my parents were its my
parents were raised in a very strict
household and my my big dad came from
like a village he came from a village
die usually I used to say it on stage
and then I realized it sounds like a
slur he came from a place called Kirti
Nagar which sounds like the N word you
can't say it it's na GA r Nagar and the
girl no you just said the my mega Newton
burger guy Midgar yeah there you go it's
closer mouth closed no I'm gonna sound
like that it's a it's a village name no
I'm trying to actually crown Sevilla's
name you know that's the truth though
yeah absolutely
but yeah so my dad is from Garrity Nagar
and he he went to a school where they
had like one book and like it was like
he was in a classroom full of like a
hundred kids and they would share one
book and he came from like just a very
different lifestyle so like the love and
affection and and all the stuff it just
he was just raised in a third-world
country
and growing up and I and I'm growing up
here I was like what's wrong with my dad
what's wrong with my family but the more
I've learned about him and his
upbringing the more I'm like oh it's
just a completely different world you
know I'm sorry I know it's really weird
and not no not at all because this is a
direct evolutionary transition you're
pushing to within the lineages
epidemiology there's so many things that
go down throughout your ancestral
lineage and one of the things is the
fact that if your mom and dad are not as
emotionally affectionate towards you and
towards them each other that directly
affects their offspring so sure yeah so
then that's gonna that's affects you you
know you may hug love touch vibe with
people differently because of that yeah
probably
one of the things I took from my my
family was like that you know there's
like two ways you can go about things a
lot of people that are like physically
or emotionally abused as children and
they they perpetuate and
continue that cycle and then there are
people that are physically mentally or
whatever abuse that decide hey I'm not
going to my parents do that to me
cars a lot of work to get through that
yeah um yeah I think it just takes like
a maturity and a lot of what yeah and
like we were talking about earlier it's
like I could be resentful of my family I
could be I could say you know like they
think we were talking about
I'm laughed about it you weren't
resentful of no you've like you like
learned and oh well laughter is the best
medicine
it really is man it really gets you
through anything and everything and it
took a long time but it's it's something
where like I we were we mentioned before
the cameras rolling you know it's like
you only get two parents you know you
only get one family no matter how long
it takes for them to come around if you
were to come around to them you got to
make it won't mess it up yeah yeah don't
mess it up I mean unless they did
something horrible and horrendous
or they should be in jail or you know
but other than that there are a lot of
things there's a lot of hurdles and
things you can get through yeah the
family there's some cool you know
there's some cool content on the site
you know we haven't we have a connection
up here where we can show you guys kind
of like you know here we have Neil sight
you know Neil Nanak on the links in the
bio I want to show a couple of the
images you know this is from Jimmy
Kimmel you had you had a couple do you
have a couple images from unnecessarily
unnecessary evil yeah there's one right
there
cool that's a young Neil in this stupid
shirt that I don't wear anymore but yeah
that's from like probably 2013 2014 baby
and yeah I think I'm doing I don't know
what joke this is that's the PlayStation
oh that's probably the place actually
that is the place and that's the Ploesti
beginning it was probably the first time
I did the PlayStation show and yeah this
is from unnecessary bullets at West
night comedy theater and yeah man it's
been a wild wild ride man that was six
years ago man I don't know this was
probably like three three four or
something like that I had a beard I when
we started the show I didn't have a
beard I was clean-shaven I was a child I
was
you definitely look like you're like 18
when you're shaving honey I look like
I'm 21 15 to 20 yeah I get I can do high
school yeah I could be in high school
musical if I wanted to yeah
so that wasn't that's a necessary evil I
want to show this because this is you
were mentioning this I think this is
really important but you know how it's
so weird that when you go on certain
sets the look conversation is really
chopped and right not a lot of what
sound bite it and stuff like that so
with Kimmel you know right when he said
you know thank you that been cut but you
know he was telling you here about how
much he likes your set yeah it was
really cool and I was hoping that would
be on I was hoping that be on the air I
was like waiting for it and then the
camera panned away and I was like no but
that part where we were laughing and
talking and shaking hands and stuff I'll
never forget that moment because yeah he
came up to me I did a joke about a guy
named Padgham as' who spells a paj a mas
which is pajamas and I did the joke and
he came up to me afterwards like is that
real it's not real guy named Pat it's
hilarious and he was we were joking
about him we were laughing and I
remember the producer that booked me on
the show we went after after the sesh I
was like hey how did it go was it okay
and she goes did you see how much he was
laughing up there I was like yeah yeah
and she's like I was gonna be on TV I
was like I know I was gonna be amazing
and then it wasn't on TV but my managers
assistant snuck these photos so this is
like behind the scenes Stubbs yeah yeah
Thank You Austin
I appreciate you man and so that's also
interesting how do you know I'm still
batteries
we are that loser tell some jokes we
good I don't know if I'm dating girls
from feeding girls you know how I ended
up in LA in comedy so um being so before
I was in comedy I I was in a band
actually I was in a scream obe and we're
actually still on MySpace you can check
out on MySpace
silence before sunrise check us out I
was in a screamo band I was the lead
guitarist and a screamer band I just did
you know because I believe because of my
strict cultural upbringing my parents
were all about math science you've my
son's gonna be a doctor or an engineer
or dead those are my three options I was
like doctor engineer or I don't have a
home and my pimp because of that I was
pretty rebellious I I started to rebel
and my wave rebelling was to jump into
the arts and to get a Gibson SG which is
the guitar with the like spikes on it
and I had an Ibanez and I was like you
know I tried to be a rock star my
parents were not supportive of that at
all and so I got a lot of my stage
presence from just being in a band and I
was in a band all throughout high school
and when we all went to college we all
broke up because everyone was going
separate ways and everything and I would
I thought about joining another band but
I realized I hate working with people so
I know I just didn't like coordinating
schedules with four other guys where
it's like we gotta you know I gotta you
know go to the drummers house when he's
available and then if the keyboardist
isn't free and then bun you gotta lug
around all its equipment and then hey we
got a show on Thursday and it's like hey
I can't make it and I got a soccer game
or and it's just like I can't I can't do
that anymore here to be an independent
content creator exactly so when I my on
Ron great so when I was in high school I
had a notebook and I would well when I
was in middle school actually I would
watch a lot of comedy central and
watch like the Comedy Central Presents
the premium blends and and a show called
comic remix where I would just play like
it'd be like Steve Harvey bit and
there's like and then it'd be like Wanda
Sykes and then and then it would go to
another comic and I would sit and watch
that with a notebook and I would write
down everybody's jokes yeah and then in
middle socratis yeah and then practice
right and then the next day I would go
to like lunch I'd be like yo check this
out and I would tell people jokes not
crediting anybody I wasn't but it wasn't
like I wrote this I was like I heard
this joke and then I would tell
everybody back to seeing the presence of
communicating a joke working with people
feeling that vibe
exactly when I was like 13 or 14 I would
do this and my sister used to make fun
of me so much looser and I was like I'm
hilarious
Vonnie and she's a couple years older
for four and a half years old or almost
five so we so I would do these jokes in
middle school and then when I got into
high school I was like I figured out
because I was writing other people's
jokes I figured out how to write a joke
just setup punchline yeah and so I
started writing my own in high school
and probably like sophomore year so I
was probably 15 16 and I started writing
my own jokes I had a notebook full of
jokes and when I was 19 I was dating
this girl and I told her about this like
I have his notebook full just all these
I used to do one-liners I was a lot like
I wanted to be like Demetri Martin or
Mitch Hedberg or Stephen Wright those
were the guys I really looked up to so I
would have a lot of like one-liners like
you know one of my earliest ones was
like I'm a lover not a fighter
which really confuses the guys that I
fight and just like really you know just
really silly punny
you know one-liners and I had a full
notebook of these and I showed them to
my girlfriend that I was like okay these
are my jokes and she was like you know
you can just tell people at a comedy
club and I was like I can't I can't do
that I thought it was either me guy
writing in my notebook
or Zach Galifianakis there was no
in-betweens I just I thought you know
that guy is an actor and then he became
a comedian or he you know I didn't know
that there was a process and she was
like no there's a process it's comedy
and 101 you already did which was you
practicing writing jokes setup punchline
getting performing in front of your
friends
exactly 102 is like oh maybe I should
actually go and bring it to a set right
so I wrote a bunch of so I was like so I
found out I was googling open mics in
Atlanta and I found the Laughing Skull
which was like a new it was a very new
club at the time was maybe like six to
ten months old and I signed up for the
open mic and they gave me a date they
were like are you gonna do October or
whatever it was like around Halloween I
had a Halloween joke and I went and I
signed up and I practice five minutes
but I thought it was we got five minutes
at the Selvam Mike and I practice in my
room well just everyday like the timing
and this and everything and I get to the
show at the Laughing Skull and I
remember thinking if I suck I'm never
gonna do this again if it's kind of like
you know I wanted to try it if I'm not
good at it then maybe it's not for me so
I had five minutes and I'm so nervous
I'm stepping on all my punchlines I'm
getting laughs but I'm stepping on all
the laughter like I was a laugh coming
and I go and then I went to the you know
and I was just going and going I ended
up doing about three three and a half
minutes you better and better at that
craft I love how you said that you're
stepping on the laughter because you're
still awkward with the energy of the
audience laughter and then you get good
at giving them space right to laugh and
let it go and then you come in on the
when it gets silent again right after
exactly it's all about timing it's all
about timing and I didn't have any
timing I wasn't I wasn't a comedian that
was my first time and so that five
minutes turned into about three and a
half and I was like okay I'm done
I don't think I had a closer I think I
don't think it was like big closed and I
was like yeah
I was just like all right bye guys and I
got off stage I got laughs and I
remember I did really well and the club
owner was hosting the mic at the time
and he was like was that your first time
I was like yeah and he was like that was
great and then everyone applauded he
said that on stage and everybody
applauded he was like please keep coming
back and I was like okay so there's like
a little bit of encouragement there and
you've gone you absolutely need that I
edited him for for helping me do comedy
and ruining my life
so haha by making me do comedy and who
was the person that encouraged was that
your girlfriend or you said your sister
that was my girlfriend was your
girlfriend my girlfriend you that
there's a next step yes she was like
sooo keep in touch with her oh no no I
do not know she lives the faro a 2,000
miles away and didn't end well so but
thank you for encouraging the very thing
I didn't know I could just go to an open
mic I I appreciate you giving me that
information
but yeah she encouraged me and you do
too and he did too well he kept me going
because he invited me back to the club
and he remember he emailed me a few
weeks later and was like hey do you want
to come do this show and at the time I
was in college and I gave my like
regular email and not my school email
and I didn't check it and I remember I
went back to the club at the open mic
like maybe a month later and I signed up
and he goes hey you didn't respond to my
email I was like what and he was like I
was trying to book you to do five
minutes on this show and I was like oh
my god I'm so sorry I thought I ruined
my comedy career I was like it's over
I'll never work again and I apologized
yeah cuz I didn't check and I went oh my
god he did email me and he was gonna
give me five minutes on a real show and
I was like I was losing my mind and he
was like yeah dude just respond X I was
like okay I promise I will and so I kept
going and he helped me get into other
venues
and he encouraged me to keep coming back
to open mic and I was also naive because
I just thought so I had five minutes and
eventually got the five minutes and the
three and a half turned into five
eventually and I got the five minutes
and for six months I kept doing the same
five minutes just doing it over and over
again refining it tightening it and blah
blah and I just thought that's all you
did as a cop I thought that was it you
have an act you got five minutes if
you're doing five minutes you do five
minutes it's the same provide it to
perfect perfection and then you just do
it forever for everybody that's it and
then you know then when you do ten okay
you add another five and then you just
always do that ten minutes I just
thought that's how it worked and he had
to tell me he had to be like oh you can
write more material I said yeah but what
about like if I'm doing five minutes
like what do I do
he's like do a couple the old and then
do a few new that I was like and it was
funny because I'm positive all the other
comedians in Atlanta were making fun of
me
they're absolutely like he's my back and
to my face class 19 and there were 30 so
they were in thought I was you know does
you know how it worked but that's what
happens when you're 19 and they're 28
and so I'm sure they were making fun of
me behind my back as well as to my face
but I didn't know I just had no idea I
didn't know any of the rules I didn't
know that there was a culture I didn't
know that there was a community I didn't
know any of the stuff it took me a long
time to learn that cuz I was a 19 year
old kid I had no idea so I did it for a
few more years and in Atlanta in Atlanta
yeah and when I I was done with school I
I thought you know I had the option or
you know I I took I would took some time
off before trying to apply to grad
school or you know do any of that stuff
and while I was doing that I was like I
want to check out either New York or Los
Angeles and I and I decided to just on a
whim go to Los Angeles and I never left
I just didn't I just never went home
I've I fell in love with the comedy and
just the abundance of
that brought you to LA well I went
checked out in New York first and I'd
been back and forth between Atlanta and
New York a lot especially I would spend
sometimes I'd spend my spend like a few
weeks there like a week there and just
run around do the mics and the shows
spark that brought me to LA was I don't
know I just glad you made the first move
to New York as well to go check out New
York yeah it's really important to go
and press your talents in larger
metropolis and just see how you vibe in
those areas with higher level talents
right right I didn't like New York
because at the time I was doing a bunch
of open mics and stuff and they weren't
as supportive as they were in Los
Angeles and I was paying money to do
open mics and I thought that was weird
that was crazy I thought that was insane
I still think that's crazy
I still think it's insane to pay money
to do there were like a dollar a minute
and it's like you know you just you mean
you take it five dollars from 40 people
you're making you know so much money and
every you know every week or every day
do an 8 o'clock in a 10 o'clock or and
then you would do like 3 mics and I'd be
like oh so I just spent like 20 bucks to
do - did you bomb - bomb to not even do
well and I always thought that was weird
and in LA I was like oh I'm not paying
this is amazing you know oh my god and
also I thought you were gonna mention
how New York has snow in you oh yeah I
can't do the weather
I just can't I couldn't do I could I
could have probably done it when I was
younger but now I'm like I don't want to
do the weather and I don't want to see
rats every day I don't want to I don't
want to have to I don't want struggling
to live to be part of my life I don't
want I don't take pride in that a lot of
people that live in New York City takes
so much pride and like oh I took three
trains and then it was snow and it's
like that doesn't make you a better
person it just makes your life more
miserable
it doesn't make you know you're the city
better because you took four trains and
saw eight rats and had to step on step
over three homeless dudes that doesn't
and there are better exercises in
character development almost always
always yeah yeah always always
especially when you can choose to do
what you
with your time rather than have to take
three trains and right absolutely
absolutely
yeah it's a time thing - its time thing
and so you're in LA you're starting to
you know see the scene there and the
scene is more attractive to you yeah and
and same with us so I when I first moved
to Los Angeles I figured I would be
proactive and start a show and I did for
you and I made some good friends and we
started a show at a place called the
lyric Hyperion theater and it was
2012-2013 and pretty quickly we put in a
lot of work it was a stand-up and sketch
show where we would do a lot of we would
do some sketches and we would do bring
up a stand-up showcase and pretty
quickly we started getting some really
awesome comics like Eric Andre and Kyle
Kinane and and we started we were
selling tickets and we were making some
decent money and it wasn't even about
the money was mostly just about the
stage time and being able to have a
place to practice our craft and I
parlayed that into I went to the
Westside comedy theater for an open mic
and I spoke to a guy there it's the
theatres in an alley and there was a guy
outside smoking a cigarette in the alley
and I was just talking this guy and I
was amazed a great theater he's like
yeah thanks man cool and I had no idea
who this guy was and I was like man this
is this venue is amazing I would love to
do a stand-up showcase here and he's
like oh really he's like you have any
experience and I was like yeah I do the
show in a silver leg the lyric hyperion
I have you know we have comics like Eric
Andre and Kyle Kinane blah blah and he
was like well I own this theater would
you like to do a showcase here and I was
like I had no idea who I was talking to
I was just talking to some dude with a
mustache
and it happened to be Sean Casey who was
an owner of the theater and I was like
all right how do we do this
I still had no idea what I'm doing and I
was like I never produced a show before
I'd produce my show and Silverlake for
less than a month for maybe three weeks
at this point or so maybe three four
weeks at this point
that was another yeah yeah doesn't mr.
show how does a show one time for three
weeks and I've had two good comics
do it and he was really cool so he he
gave me his email I said okay cool let
me email you I met in his office we
picked a day and his the whole thing was
alright let's pick a day and we'll see
how it goes you know see what we can do
and so we picked a day and I brought
along and brought on two friends as
producers and we picked a day and we got
this the lineup was insane for our first
show
it's insane because then it would they
were all really good comics they were
the best comics we could get but now
they're all famous it wasn't that our
lineup was like it was like tone bells
Sean Patton Ali Wong Laurie Kilmartin
like it was just an insane lineup of
comedians and I was like this you know
this should sell out you know and
anywhere in the country if that were in
the lineup there were the Midwest
it'd be a 300-500 state theater West
Side comedy theater is about 75 to 100
seats it's not huge it's kind of it's
like a little workout it's a great room
and it's a great sized theater to see
comedy you but it's not huge it's not
you know it's not a theater by any means
but so we got this lineup together and
again I had never really produced much
of a show and my show in Silver Lake was
just me bringing a bunch of my friends
and people that lived on that side so we
did a lot of online marketing Facebook
ads and like we submitted to a bunch of
event sites and blogs and then I prayed
I prayed a lot that people would show up
I just pray that's all I doubt that's my
work that was what I did
I booked a great lineup I put it out
there onto the Internet into the world
and I told as many people as I could to
buy tickets and I spread word of mouth
and Facebook and everything that I was
available I don't even think Instagram
existed at this point well I think
Instagram was very new it just started
so no one was really doing ads on it
today and you just listed the the
process of you do all this hard work to
with an event you get the event moving
as an as a something that you hope gains
traction and your best to give it that
that those are just those variables to
give it good traction I and then you
just pray what you do you know you pray
you pray you do
you because you you know you took that
risk and that's so important of doing
that show it's a slight risk that we've
been talking about how to take those
risks yeah thanks Ron
what is that we have a minute no it's
1500 so anyways minute times so I prayed
and I prayed and I prayed and we ended
up selling out the first show it was
just packed it was sold out and it was
an incredible showcase the owner was
there he saw it he was more than happy
and then we started little by little
getting a couple more dates on the books
we got the next like month we got like
two Friday's yeah and then the next
month we got like two and then like and
then it became like three and then it
turned into do you want to do this every
week and I was like yeah I'd love to do
this every week so within like three or
four months we were doing every Friday
night at the Westside comedy theater and
at this point the club had been doing a
lot of improv and not a lot of standup
so we were kind of filling a void yeah
and bringing stand-up to the theater and
bringing stand-up comics the theater a
lot of times we would book a lot of
great comics and they'd be like we've
never been here before I've never
performed here before and ended up being
now it's now it's about 50/50 or even
like 60/40 stand-up improv at the
theater but so that turned into a weekly
show and we've been doing it for six
years and now it's kind of a well-oiled
machine you know it's just it we put out
a good lineup it sells out and we get
awesome drop ins like Sandler and Howie
Mandel and a lot of crazy people so and
again a so much fits that risk you know
you're just hanging out so this is it in
Santa Monica you're in that alley with
guys I'm in an alley with the weird dude
wearing has a moustache smoking a
cigarette and I was like I guess I'll
talk to this dude and he gave me an
opportunity and I took it I ran with it
I think a lot of a lot of my career and
a lot of art in general and stand-up in
general I can't speak to like every I
can't be like and rappers I can't I
can't speak that you know and you know
painter sees but and nurses but a lot of
my career in stand-up has been taking
opportunities I don't know I'm not
necessarily ready for and then rising to
the occasion exactly that is what you
have to do
cuz and I think if you care enough about
it you can rise the occasion the first
time I was told to do ten I was told I'm
doing ten minutes do you think I how
would I have to how would I know I had
ten minutes you know the first time I
had to feature of somebody doing twenty
minutes I didn't know I had twenty
minutes but i sat there and I wrote and
I tagged and I said okay this is an old
bit I'll bring back and this is that I
put it in order and I practice and I
rose to the occasion yeah the first time
I had to do an hour first time I had to
do a headlining set I had to do a
college and I was literally about to
[ __ ] my pants in my hotel I was at my
hotel room and I written down every joke
I had ever written praying that it was
gonna be an hour praying that that would
be enough ended up being an hour and 20
minutes which was insane they were like
get off stage but uh I had no idea I
didn't I didn't know I couldn't time
myself I didn't know I had gone 20
minutes over but you just have to take
the opportunities you're not ready for
take the risk and rise to the occasion
that's the only way to grow it's the
only way to know if you're ready for
things and you're gonna fail you're
gonna fail I'm not saying a hundred
percent of the time I rose the occasion
or sometimes I would do the job but
barely you know I would do the 20
minutes but eight of it sucked you know
or I would do the hour and 24 minutes
were awful but you know you learn you
you learn that okay I need to fix this I
need to work on that and I highly
recommend taking opportunities you may
not be ready for and just going for it
it's so important and I I realized that
the first couple times I did it I was
like okay so I guess this is how it
works you know that is so well said um
I'm just gonna leave it there yes so
well said Neil I'm really excited for
that segment to be heard by people true
it's so well said my man oh thank you
rise to the occasion even when you're
not ready yeah I mean are we learning
growth we talked about kimmel and stuff
I I'd never done late-night I just I
never done and when I did my comedy
central's set I'd never done a set on
television when would be the right time
yeah what would be the right time when
yeah how are you prepare for something
you've never
go for it you know I need another year
yeah I was ever I would never ever it's
it's very there's a lot of things that
people will tell you in your career and
a lot of it stems from resentment or
from a lot of it stems from their own
insecurities or the resentment and a lot
of things that you know people in all
our forms whether it's music or comedy
whatever will tell you comes from their
own sense of failure you just have to do
what you think is best for you you have
to do what instinctually works for you
always go with your gut always go with
your instinct and listen to people's
advice but take everything with a grain
of salt you know as well said thank you
well done you like hanging out with you
a lot
yeah like a you know what do you man
yeah Jamie other questions I I do I do
all right I want to ask you about
political correctness in comedy we don't
have much time but I just want to at
least hear some of your thoughts about
how that's been affecting the comedy
scene over their career well I do think
one thing that I think is one thing I'm
excited about is I do think the pendulum
is swinging I do think people are
getting tired of hearing the same TED
talk over and over again hearing the
same points over and over again and
people are realizing hey these are great
ideas these are great thoughts but this
isn't necessarily comedy it's not
necessarily funny you're making a what I
call it as humorous observations you're
making a humorous observation you're not
really making a joke you know and as far
as political correctness goes into
comedy it is pretty prevalent you have
to be careful about what you say
humorous observations that you're
talking about are ones where the person
is being politically correct yeah you're
being politically correct and you're
making a joke but it's not necessarily
you're making a humorous observation and
that's not necessarily a joke
you're Yorick waiting something or
you're finding an analogy that's related
to what the agenda you're trying to push
as opposed to what's funny about the
situation it's not necessarily a joke
it's more oh okay that's a humorous
point within the box of what's allowed
yes within the box of what's allowed and
as far as like what's allowed and what's
not allowed there is absolutely a void
there's I personally if you just say
your village name you know I understand
like why it's about absolutely oh yeah
also at the same time it's like it's a
it's a villain oh no I'm not upset with
you about I don't think anybody cares I
know you're trying to say you know
there's many things but there but I will
say I've so I used to say it on stage I
used to say my dad's from keerthi Nagar
and the crowd would go immediately and I
know I'm not I was just worried from
that's what I'm saying you know and I
had to stop saying it I would say Punjab
which is the state that keerthi Nagar TC
because it's more peace it's just and
and the thing about comedy is it is
psychological
there are things are gonna turn people
off whom I can make the same joke five
times and it's gonna turn off so many
people or it's not gonna turn off some
people and I could change one word or I
could change one phrase like I changed
gifting a gun to Punjab I had no problem
nobody second-guessed it nobody thought
I was trying to say something I
shouldn't be saying they just thought oh
he's had Punjab that's I've heard of it
I know what that is that's safe and it
is psychological so a lot of times I
will you can still make the same point
you can still make the same joke by
changing the wording you know there are
jokes I say that start off offensive
where I'll I'll tell the joke or the
first or second time and people are
offended people I think I've crossed a
line and then I'll sit and go which part
of it did people what words made people
go that's maybe you shouldn't say that
and then I'll change those words and
I'll go okay okay I'm still gonna make
the same joke but I'm gonna figure out
what I can say to appease people you
basically write the jokes several
different times the changing things and
see how audiences react exactly exactly
authors do that a lot yeah absolutely
it's I mean comedy is all about the art
is all about editing and it's all about
taking things out and adding things in
adding tags and all that kind of stuff
but what I was saying about the pendulum
swinging is there has been a lot of
political correct comedy
out there's a lot of specials there are
a lot of shows on television that cater
to a specific audience and I do think
people are getting tired of it I think
people are ready to hear people are
ready to be offended again or they're
beginning to be ready to be offended
again beginning to be ready to be
offended again Wow and what I mean by
that is an example of that it is there I
say there's a void because I just worked
with the comedian recently I'm a huge
fan of this guy he's super funny if you
get a chance you should check him out
everyone listening should absolutely
check him out
he's a guy named Andrew Schultz he has
an amazing album and it's an album
because he tried to sell it as a special
and every Network turned it down
because it was offensive he says things
that are slightly sexist or slightly
racist or slight and within a within a
you know a realm it's not like he's not
like saying slurs or anything yeah he's
not saying anything crazy but it is a
little edgy and it's a little edgy yeah
it's edgy on the line it's I would say
too online I don't think it's I don't
think any of its over the line some
people may but I don't think any of its
over the line and he hadn't so he put it
out as an album and he put it out his
special he taped a special and couldn't
sell it so he put her on YouTube and
clips every clip from the special could
he cut it up into pieces has gone viral
every single one has hit
I think he's over 10 million views at
this point his album was the number one
album in the world for two weeks he sold
more records than cardi B his first week
he put out his album it was it was
insane the numbers were insane and now
he went he went from selling 50 tickets
every club he went to to selling out
theaters he's selling out 1,500 seats in
every city he goes to because of YouTube
this album and because of this void he's
the only one who's out here saying what
everyone wishes comedians would say and
it's beautiful because now every network
is like hey when's your next special
what's going on what's going on you know
they're seeing the numbers and they're
seeing the support and they're seeing
his following grow and he did that
himself he just put it out they said
this is who I am I'm Angie I'm offensive
and I'm not going to be PC and I'm not
going to clean up my act and people all
over the world because he also he did a
European tour because he toured the
United States he's still touring right
now selling out
he posted a date he was like I'm gonna
be in Chicago and that show sold out
within minutes and then he said should I
add another show and then every once in
all of his fans yeah you had another
show out of the second show sold out he
ended up doing five shows in Chicago
because he tapped into how much demand
there how much demand there was and
there's and he was I worked with him
recently he spoke to me is like there's
a void man people want to see this
people with the pendulum is swinging we
people are coming back to it and I'm
really excited about that
I do think there are things you
shouldn't say I do think that don't be
hurtful and I also you know be very
respectful yeah yeah there's a quote
there's a quote from Carlin where and
it's an interesting and I don't know I
don't know the exact quote I would you
know look it up but basically he said he
basically says that we should we
shouldn't we should comedy takes aim at
people who have more power than us
Connie takes aim at people who aren't
disenfranchised to not make fun of
people like like the LGBTQ community and
stuff like that they're disenfranchised
they're at a disadvantage comedy is not
about kicking them while they're down
piece is about kicking them while
they're up and so you know you can make
fun of people like I make fun of like I
have a new joke when I make from the
Kardashians bunch and people get like
how could you women and it's like no
they're fine they're fine and billions
of they're fine they're okay don't worry
about them and people are starting to
come around to it the joke is like it
like I said I had to edit it and fix it
and work on it but now it's working
it's where there's definitely a joke in
the fact that you on musk can land two
rockets at the same time to each other
and then people will still troll him and
hate him oh absolutely there's for sure
Joe absolutely and so what you're doing
is you're pulling from these different
sources right and make crafting this
this joke and yeah so I I think that
there has been some benefit to political
correctness and comedy people are being
smarter wiser yeah choosing their
it's more wisely but as far as like the
biggest thing to police a comedians
material is when you don't laugh that is
that's how you cut it out if you don't
if there's something that the comedians
saying that you disagree with or you or
you think is offensive or you think is
wrong you don't laugh and that comedian
can't tell the joke again
I can't tell a joke more I will try a
joke two or three times if people don't
laugh I know I went too far or it wasn't
funny or I need to rewrite it or I need
to throw it away so and eventually I'll
throw it away if something doesn't work
several times it's out of my act
different jokes in different
demographics - you can I'll try it yeah
fun about Trump in like a lair SF in New
York and poblano Boko connington in the
middle oh I post stuff on about Trump
wherever I go because if it's a good
enough joke everybody will laugh I've
poked fun about Trump in rural Illinois
and Montana and Georgia and the you know
all of in Tennessee and Alabama
that was a toughest one out of a my
split the room but then I got him back
but I but if the joke is good enough you
can poke fun of anybody if the joke is
funny enough it doesn't matter where you
are it's universally funny yeah there's
always gonna be an off night here and
there but if it's a great joke it'll
work everywhere well said about PC into
the pendulum really well okay last
question what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world what is the
most beautiful thing in the world
laughter thing laughter is most
beautiful because that's universal it's
absolutely universal you do something
silly if somebody sees Jim Carrey and
Dumb and Dumber you know again hit by
the airbag some dude in China who
doesn't speak English is gonna laugh you
know that's beautiful
exactly yeah it brings people together
it absolutely brings everyone together
and I love that about comedy and I love
that about laughter so I would usually
think about a question like that I'm
getting heckled Rayna
I'm getting heckled by laughter it's
disgusting ugly I would usually think
about a question like that but I think
the most beautiful thing in the world is
laughter and give me quick that feeling
what does that do for you the
laughter because all of us when we feel
after there's something so special about
it like what is it it's nothing else
matters in that moment but but you to
joy that you're feeling when you have a
room laughing together they forget about
their problems they forget about
everything that they forget about the
mortgage and their job and like how much
they hate their wife and how much you
know and how much their kids are costing
them or how they their daughter wrecked
their car or whatever you know they just
forget about what happened that day and
they laugh and that's my goal my goal is
to go to your city and make you forget
about your your shitty week your shitty
night your shitty date or your breakup
or your or maybe better yeah well make
your debut or if you had a great day I
want to make it better I want you know
or I want you to relate or whatever but
the beautiful thing about laughter is it
brings people together and it helps
people who take their mind off of things
and and I so I think laughter is the
most beautiful thing in the world and
your incredible human am i yeah you are
I think you are thank you man I think I
think you have silly art and even in
just a couple days of knowing each other
I'm just like that's why I said your
incredible human you're a great dude man
you you take you take a lot of different
aspects of humanity and you crunch them
in with comedy and I like that a lot
it's a very multidisciplinary approach
to reality and using comedy as a medium
like you were talking about laughing has
all been really awesome you and I you
know I wish you the best and I hope to
host you again when you come back to the
Bay Area in the future we can't continue
having conversation on packing things go
check out Neil's show for those in Los
Angeles unnecessary evil the link is in
the bio
check out Neil's website also Neil
nodded comm links in the bio would check
them out contact in there get in touch
also give us your comments on the show
we'd love to hear from you let us know
what you thought go and create go and
build go and manifest your destiny into
the world go execute everyone thanks Ron
for producing and directing thanks for
joining us I think everyone at home much
love we'll see you soon
[Music]
you